انتصار بنكهه الحذر اعلنت هوموسكو في
باخمت وان كان الاعتماد فيه على قوات
فاجنر للسيطره على تلك المدينه فقط فلا بد
لها من اعاده ترتيب صفوف القوات الروسيه
الرسميه باختصار القوات الروسيه تتغير
على مدى اشهر استنزفت روسيا قوات النخبه
التي عرفت باسم سبيس على خطوط قتال
الاماميه تستعد عنها اليوم بقوات شتورم
وفق ما بينته وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
مجموعه طيران من طراز النخبه قد تشهد
مبارزه قاسيه مع مقاتلات اف 16 في سماء
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وحده مدعمه بمقاتلات الجويه
وطائراتها تتولى مهام الهجوم الارضي
تقدم حققته القوات الروسيه متوغله في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه طوال فتره الحرب
وقبلها في شبه جزيره القرم مكتسبات
ستحميها موسكو بكل السبل متركزه في نقاط
اساسيه معظمها جنوب اوكرانيا بحسب
خنادق وحواجز وتحصينات رصدتها البي بي سي
من خلال صور الاقمار الصناعيه لتحدد تمركز
نقاط الدفاع والتكتيكه الدفاعيه
جنوب اقليم زابوريا حيثما تزال المعارك
محتدمه هو مفتاح لبوابه شبه جزيره القرم
ونقطه هدف للهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
مطار برديانسك بقرب بحر ازوف والذي يعتبر
قاعده رئيسيه للمقاتلات الروسيه
كل منسك شماليه شبه الجزيره
بوابات اساسيه للقرم بالاضافه لحمايه
الطريق اي 105 الواصل بين ميليتو بول التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا وخر كيف الاوكرانيه
رعب انتشر قبل الان بين الدول الاوروبيه
الاعضاء في حلف الناتو من توسع روسيا على
حدودها الرعب بات الان من التورط في حرب
كبرى فكيف للحلف ان يواجه جيشا في طور
التحول ويخرج من معارك قاسيه لتشدد مجله
نيوز على ضروره احدى تغييرات على قوات
الحلف لمواجهه خصمها في الشرق الى عمر
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات